[Music]
Jupiter Uranus Saturn earth sadly
the earth didn't make it onto the list
of the solar systems ringed planets if
it did would it still be able to host
life this is what if and here's what
would happen if the earth had rings like
Saturn when the earth was young it most
likely had a ring of rock debris around
it four-and-a-half billion years ago
another planet
theya hit the earth the giant impact
sent a ring of matter hurtling into the
Earth's orbit but it didn't stay like
that for long the rocky debris soon
formed another celestial body the one we
now call the moon having planetary rings
visible in the sky would look way more
spectacular than just one gray Rock
right maybe but if our planet got
beautiful rings like these tomorrow much
of life on Earth might not survive the
renovation process
it wouldn't necessarily take another
collision to form rings around the earth
we could just crumble the moon and for
that we'd only need to move it a little
closer the gravitational pull that our
planet exists on the moon isn't equal
everywhere it's much stronger on the
side of the moon that is closest to us
there is a limit on how close celestial
bodies can be to each other it's called
the Roche limit if they get any closer
than that limit the larger body threads
the smaller one into pieces the distance
of the Roche limit depends on the size
mass and density of the two objects for
instance the Sun rips up comets that
come within 1.3 million kilometers of it
the earth will tear apart an
average-sized comet from approximately
18,000 kilometers away for the moon the
Roche limit would be about 9,500
kilometers
the Rings we might get from something
the size of the moon would be about five
thousand kilometers wide and around nine
and a half kilometers thick but unlike
Saturn's icy rings ours would be made of
nothing but rock the earth is just too
close to the Sun to keep the debris ice
looking out of the sky you'd be able to
see these rings from Earth at all times
because of the brightness of the Rings
the moon wouldn't seem as bright anymore
that is if we still had the moon if the
moon crumbled up and became our rings
well there'd be nothing else up there to
look at and there would be some other
consequences the Rings
suddenly hugging earth would disrupt
internal navigation systems of some
animals if not enough direct sunlight
was making it through the Rings they
would also affect photosynthesis and our
oxygen supply in the shadow of the Rings
with no contact from the sun's rays the
temperature would get so cold that it
would make the shadowed areas of the
earth almost uninhabitable
communications satellites generally
placed around the earth's equator would
find themselves right in the middle of a
rock storm we need to find another way
to keep the internet alive if we want to
keep posting selfies on a ring to earth
we'd be better off in a scenario where
the earth has always been like this
provided we didn't lose sunlight and
oxygen we'd evolved just fine but we'd
have to develop other means of
communication since we wouldn't be able
to send satellites into an orbit full of
rocks space would never become our final
frontier
the rocky rings around the planet would
be a sort of orbital barbed-wire fence
keeping us all grounded and just like
the rings of Saturn births rings
wouldn't last forever one day they'd
start to feel their age and drop from
the sky make sure to wear a helmet and
don't forget to look up and enjoy the
show
if the multiverse is real there might be
a ringed earth somewhere out there with
people on it wondering what it would be
like to live on a planet with no rings
but we'll leave that story for another
what-if